kurulum enjekte insanlar Amerika'nın
sonunda çocuklarımı sipariş ettiğini düşündüler, bu yüzden
genç bir bayan görüntüleri aldım, eğer
kalırlarsa, bu bir çellodaki çeşitli
kurucuları özetliyor bir açık kanal D
onun adı - ya da güzel
, videodaki bilgimden gurur duyuyor.
bir Apatosaurus başlatır
[Alkış]
Rüyaların tamamen yeşil olduğunu görüyorum
[Müzik]
I
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
iyi alev
bebeğim
[Müzik]
bir performans en çok yaptığınız nokta
118 yani sadece
işaretini almalısın, o
çingeneyi almaya sadık kalacaksınız, popüler konuşabilecekler, neredeyse
ana ağlarını
daireye bağlayacaklar ve sadece bir bütçe
sunmalıdır.
] Maggie'ye
[Müzik
] Larry
[Müzik]
Oh